Maman j'ai raté l'avion et c'est
peut-être la meilleure chose que je ne
souhaite à nous d'arriver en retard
d'arriver en retard à cette course
effrénée qui n'a ni fin ni finalité je
vous souhaite d'arriver en retard à ce
rendez-vous qui nous condamne de rater
notre propre enterrement en quelque
sorte et notre salut se trouve lui dans
l'atterrissage alors pour toutes ces
fois on est monté dedans on l'a pas
loupé cet avion il nous a amené à
détruire ce qu'on allait voir
ce qu'on aurait quand même embarqué si
on avait su qui nous amènerait vers des
Gorges du Verdon sans eau des mers de
glace sans glace une Amazonie sans arbre
alors oui c'est dur injuste fatigant
parce qu'il faut dire qu'à coup de
milliards on s'est assuré de faire
naître en nous le désir de s'envoyer en
l'air et c'est vrai qu'elle est belle la
vie vue d'un hublot je repense souvent à
cette publicité d'Air France qu'on
voyait parfois dans le métro en rentrant
d'une longue journée de boulot à travers
les vitres sales on pouvait lire évader
vous et bien sûr que j'avais envie d'y
être moi aussi dans cette sublime robe à
voler dans les airs et puis à me
réveiller en Caraïbes en quelques heures
le lendemain bien sûr qu'on a envie de
bouffer le monde pour être sûr de rien
ni louper d'aller voir partout tout le
monde pour s'assurer de ne rien manquer
mais cette force du refus qui nous sauve
je l'ai trouvé en apprenant que ce désir
n'était pas le mien
on s'évade de prison pas de son
quotidien
la bonne nouvelle c'est qu'on peut se
laisser bouleverser par son voisin vivre
1000 aventures en partance top en
Bretagne en vélo en Camargue en dormant
la belle étoile dans les Pyrénées qu'on
n'aura pas assez d'une vie pour
parcourir l'Europe en train gravir tous
nos sommets visitez tous nos villages
que la beauté du monde est partout où on
réapprend la voir la bonne nouvelle
c'est qu'il est encore temps d'atterrir
peut-être que l'urgence maman c'est
précisément de rater l'avion